hi everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live lits game I just put a seek
out for somebody 2000 or greater ok got
a guy that's 21:58 I'll try the King
pawn opening for once
yeah let's go into the Ruby Lopez maybe
there we go
I don't play this often at all
I rarely respond 'if I've in response to
e4 and I'm not really a fan of that
Berlin defense so I'm going to avoid
that Bishop e2 is fairly common move at
this point Queen e2 not used to really
seeing that again I don't play this
opening but I mean I've gotten through
games from this opening I don't really
see Queen 2 e 2 C 3 followed up with D 4
and H 3 things like that
I think b5 is good here chase the bishop
back and just Castle not sure if I want
to go 1 or 2 squares of my pawn so I'll
reserve that option
that's why castled first all right so
now d4 he really is d4 if I take he get
push alright so I'll just do this if he
pushes I could that's not sure that's
great I think this was needed first to
prevent this pin alright let's go with
this
I think this pin could be very annoying
wow he's placing another piece along
this diagonal
he's also placing his rook op opposite
my queen so I have to watch out for that
hmm where I put my queen because there's
a lot of pressure on this a 5 point
right now
this pin I want to be able to maintain
this pin hmm do I take take and then
night here something I'm really not sure
what to do
I don't like that is rook is opposite my
queen that's for sure what's my plan
from here I really don't have one
maybe queen here I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna move
I really don't um this is just strictly
just to get off of this D file I don't
I'm really not I don't have any other
meaning beyond that alright so I just
want to maintain this pin if he wants to
really get out of this pin he's gonna
have to weaken his Kings side with g4
and then this becomes a hole and this
becomes a hole am I gonna be able to
take advantage of it I don't know all
right so I think rook here is a choice
or pawn takes maybe I should look
forward to opening up the position
because then I think I might be a bit
more bothersome for him to not be able
to move this Knight in an open position
so it takes and then rook here takes and
then here maybe I'll go here and wait
for his knight to move and only then
will I take actually who wouldn't be
able to do that hmm I'm I'm gonna go
with this if he pushes I'll go here
attack his bishop if he plays a knight
here he's gonna lose end up losing
opponent I believe if Knight here takes
he might have to push here first right
here would block the rooks view of the
d4 square not sure what he'll do here
maybe g4 pawn push pawn take I just take
one my knight and he's I'm just adding
pressure to this pin piece that probably
wouldn't be a good choice pawn to a4
attacking here for a second time I might
follow up what rook b8 you know try that
it takes I'll just recapture as usual
I'm low on time so I have to kind of
fight my way back into this one takes
takes what does he do here Knight here
night here pawn push this is a nice open
file for his rook I could push here next
actually if he pushes here I can no
longer make use of this knight move here
or here so this might be a good move
yeah actually here I'd have to go here
and this is this is awkward d5 ya have
to go here
here here here maybe pawn push at some
point this is this still must be
somewhat annoying to him I'm assuming at
some point he's just gonna have to push
g4 to allow this knight to move all
right here and then here if I push
actually if I go here you could take
this pawn I'm gonna push here first if
he pushes then this is a nice square for
my knight actually I could coordinate my
Knights very nicely in this square
Knight b7 to c5 I think this is a this
is a good plan at this point take all
right so my rook has pressure here
he has pressure along this C file I want
to get my knight here ASAP and I could
do that with this right here
it's also worth taking to combat my
bishop here's this is considered my bad
bishop as a result of my pawns being on
dark squares and this is this is his bad
bishop since he has pawns on light
squares fixed and so I would like to
trade this bishop for this bishop if
possible so Knight here would probably
be a good choice if he plays real key
I'll just go here alright that's a good
move I'm gonna come here I want to be
able to maintain a knight on this square
oh that's annoying what do I do
he's pinning my knight here here I want
to go here get out of the pin and I want
to be able to maybe advance here at some
point to strike at this central pawn so
I had a couple ways to get out of it all
right he finally allows this knight to
move I have pressure against this pawn
my bishop is stopping the knight from
coming out here usually the knight would
want to come here to here boy I'm in
trouble I think yeah well I'm all
bottled up here maybe I come here let's
try
no I don't like that my rook this rook
is opposite my Queen Queen here I'm in
rough shape Queen here and then Knight
here this pawn is taking away my knight
right here is garbage oh this is bad he
has all the play um there's no way I'm
better at this point in the game I'm
gonna try that actually I think Queen
here is gonna be good Queen here I'm
pinning his Bishop to his rook Queen
here all right I want to get out of this
pin if take stakes and then this rook is
guarding my Brooks are connected oh boy
I'm in rough shape all right yeah right
here
Queen here is probably good clean here
I'll win upon I'll have to go here takes
takes takes yeah this is no good rook
here I'm done my queen is trapped No ah
where did I go wrong in this game I
can't lose to this guy
21:58 was a llama Raider than me yes I
could lose the first game of the new
year that I try to record mm-hmm
all right I think I'm going to resign
yep resignation time so where did I go
wrong I really don't know I need your
help so if you have any suggestions feel
free to fire them my way
thanks bye